this episode is brought to you by tonal
t-o-n-a-l
i'm super excited about this one and i
was skeptical
of it in the beginning tonal quote tonal
is the world's most intelligent home gym
and personal trainer end quote that's
the tagline
from their website folks to give you the
one sentence summary and
this device it's really a system is
perfect for anyone looking to take their
home workouts to the next level or
someone who just wants to get maximum
bang for the buck
in a tiny tiny footprint of space
tonal is precision engineered to be the
world's most advanced strength studio
and personal trainer it uses
breakthrough technology of all different
types
to help get you stronger faster i was
introduced to tonal by three different
friends all of them are tech savvy
one of them is a former competitive
skier who's doubled his strength in a
number of movements using tonal even
though he has a
long athletic background and i'll paint
a picture for you by eliminating
traditional metal weights dumbbells and
barbells tonal can deliver 200 pounds of
resistance which doesn't sound like a
lot but it's actually
it feels like a lot more at the high end
in a device smaller than a flat screen
tv and you can perform at least 150
different exercises and these different
technologies are exclusive to tonal and
you can dial weights up and down
with the touch of a button in one pound
increments using magnets and electricity
so the movement is extremely smooth
and even though i have a home gym
already in my garage i'm still getting a
tonal installed i've used
tonal for multiple workouts now to do
things i just cannot do
in my home gym such as the chop and lift
exercises from the four hour body all
sorts of cable exercises that would
usually
involve much much bigger piece of
equipment eccentric
training for instance you can do to give
a simple example
bicep curls where you are lifting let's
just say
20 pounds in each hand up and then tonal
will automatically
increase the weight because you can
lower more than you can lift to say
25 or 30 pounds on the way down and i do
kettlebell swings i do all sorts of
deadlifts this that and the other thing
and after one workout
on tonal focusing on pulling i was
blasted for a full
week it's really incredible what you can
do with eccentrics
they also have all sorts of other really
really cool
advantages that you can apply to any of
your favorite movements
tonal learns from your strength and
provides suggested weight
recommendations for every move with
detailed progress reports to help you
see your strengths grow
tonal also has a growing library of
expert-led workouts by motivating
coaches from strength training
to cardio so you can do really just
about everything every program is
personalized
to your body using artificial
intelligence and other
aspects of the engineering and smart
features check your form in real time
just like a personal trainer
so try it out try tonal at least check
it out watch
the videos on youtube and see if you can
pick out a familiar voice
it's not me i'll say that but try tonal
the world's smartest home gym
for 30 days in your home and if you
don't love it you can return it for a
full refund
so visit www.tonal.com
for 100 off of smart accessories when
you use promo code tim
tim at checkout that's www.tonal.com
promo code tim tonal be your strongest
this episode is brought to you by
element spelled lmnt
what on earth is element it is a
delicious sugar-free
electrolyte drink mix i've stocked up on
boxes and boxes of this it was one of
the first things that i bought
when i saw covid coming down the pike
and i usually use one to two per day
element is formulated to help anyone
with their electrolyte needs and
perfectly suited to folks following a
keto low carb
or paleo diet or if you drink a ton of
water and you might not
have the right balance that's often when
i drink it or if you're doing any type
of endurance exercise
mountain biking etc another application
if you've ever struggled to feel good
on keto low-carb paleo it's most likely
because even if you're consciously
consuming electrolytes
you're just not getting enough and it
relates to a bunch of stuff like a
hormone called aldosterone blah blah
blah when insulin is low but suffice to
say
this is where element again spelled lmnt
can help my favorite flavor by far is
citrus salt
which is a side note you can also use to
make a kick ass
no sugar margarita but for special
occasions obviously
you're probably already familiar with
one of the names behind it
rob wolff robb rob wolff who is a former
research biochemist and
two-time new york times best-selling
author of the paleo solution and wired
to eat
rob created element by scratching his
own itch
that's how it got started his brazilian
jiu jitsu coaches turned him onto
electrolytes
as a performance enhancer things clicked
and bam
company was born so if you're on a low
carb diet or
fasting electrolytes play a key role in
relieving hunger cramps headaches
tiredness
and dizziness sugar artificial
ingredients coloring
all that's garbage unneeded there's none
of that in element
and a lot of names you might recognize
are already using element it was
recommended to be
by one of my favorite athlete friends
three navy seal teams as prescribed by
their master chief marine units
fbi sniper teams at least five nfl teams
who have subscriptions
they are the exclusive hydration partner
to team usa weightlifting and on and on
you can try it risk free if you don't
like it element will give you your money
back no questions asked they have
extremely low return rates
element came up with a very special
offer for you my dear listeners for a
limited time you can claim a
free element sample pack you only cover
the cost of shipping
for u.s customers this means you can
receive an eight-count sample pack
for just five dollars simply go to drink
element.com
tim that's drinklmnt.com tim
to claim your free eight count sample
pack one more time that's drink
lmnt.com tim for this exclusive offer
drinkelement.com tim check it out
at this altitude i can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start to
shake
can
[Music]
i'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal endoscopy
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the tim ferriss show
where it is my job to interview and
attempt to deconstruct world-class
performers of all different types from
all different fields
my guest today steffy cohen s-t-e-f-i
cohen on instagram at steffie cohen
she is a 25-time world record holding
powerlifter and the first woman in the
history of the sport to deadlift 4.4
times her body weight we will
we will give some examples of what that
might mean i weigh around 170 pounds
that means i have to deadlift i think
around 748 pounds
i've got a ways to go but uh we're not
going to turn this into my therapy
session just yet
steffy is a doctor of physical therapy
author podcast host and business owner
passionately educating people with her
evidence-based view
on all things training and nutrition
she's the co-owner of hybrid performance
method
where hundreds of thousands of strength
seekers go monthly to find progressive
strength training and nutrition programs
plus tons
of free articles and videos steffi's
creative mind loves collaborating with
the hybrid team and partners to develop
powerful content inspired fashion
in both fitness and nutrition tools for
a stronger life her new book is back in
motion which we'll certainly talk about
at one point
and you can find her all over the place
website hybridperformancemethod.com
instagram
if you want to be both impressed
astonished maybe feel like you need to
put in some more work
you can go to instagram forward slash
steffy cohen again that's s-t-e-f-i you
can find her on youtube easily
she has podcast hybrid unlimited steffy
welcome to the show thank you so much
tim thank you for having me i'm super
excited to be here
i'm excited to have you on i've been
texting with some
mutual friends of ours i want to give
credit where credit is due to
matt vincent for initially suggesting
that this happened so for those who
don't know matt incredible
athlete highland games and beyond also
an all-around wacky hilarious character
who despite
being built like a grizzly bear can also
out mountain bike me over
many many hundreds of miles which really
broke my spirit but that's a separate
story
that is so yeah i was like he's gonna
look like a bear on a tricycle
definitely i won't be in last place he
just had knee surgery and then
smoked completely smoked me uh kelly
starrett also
and uh i have an embarrassment of riches
here in terms of questions for you
because
i have done my homework i believe
and there are an infinite number of
directions we can go i thought we would
start
and i very rarely start biographically
but i think here it could be
interesting at least it's my curiosity
where were you born
and what was your childhood like i was
born in caracas venezuela this is south
america
i was born i'm a venezuelan jew so i was
born in a very traditional
household most of my childhood i spent
playing soccer i played soccer for the
national
venezuelan soccer team which sounds a
lot more impressive than what it
actually was like
there was not a lot of funding from the
government for
professional sports back home so we
kind of played in dirt fields we played
in
a field that was located at the military
base
which was interesting traveling in the
inner parts of the country
was super eye-opening for me given that
i come from a more kind of like
sheltered
family environment you know my dream
with soccer was always to
get into a d1 team or play professional
soccer
i really wanted to play professionally
in in any capacity
for a long time ended up moving to the
states
looking for a soccer scholarship moved
to san diego
and i guess i don't know how far you
want me to go there but
well i that's where i come from yeah
we're going to go pretty far with it
for those who have never been to
venezuela
you're actually the second venezuelan
born guest i've had on the show the
first is
jason silva who is definitely you know
venezuelan
and i would love to just hear you
describe
what your experience was like or rather
the reasons for leaving venezuela at
what age
i don't have many memories of venezuela
as
a you know peaceful tranquil
friendly country when i was already
growing up when i was 10 12
the country started getting pretty
dangerous there was a lot of
political and economical unrest there
was a lot of divide between social
classes
there was a lot of corruption
dictatorship
disguised as a socialist government
growing up there
is very differently than anything in any
other country really like
talking about bulletproof cars i'm
talking about bodyguards
talking about you know the fear of
constant fear anytime you
get out of your house to either be
kidnapped to either be shot either be
armed robbed either be i don't know take
it into your house and
getting everything stolen from you so
it's a very kind of high stress high
alert
way to live and i guess when you don't
know anything better that just kind of
becomes your norm right when you grow up
in an environment
that's a certain way you just grow up to
accept that that's just
i guess how the world works so very
sheltered
you know you you're always kind of
spending time within the same groups
with the same people uh going to and
from the same places
uh not really like socializing much
outside of that you live in a
in your little kind of crystal ball
essentially
and at the time i think this was 1998 or
2002 i can't remember which one of those
elections was
when there was a civil war chavez the
president at that time
didn't win the elections and there was
this huge civil war a ton of people died
my
my dad was in this in the protest i went
to the protest it was very graphic it
was very interesting time to live and
very interesting experience
uh as well and i guess that's when
when that all happened and i guess
chavez got back into the into power
somehow even though he wasn't elected by
the people at that time it was very
clear to me and my family that
there was just not gonna be anything
that could save that country right like
the wrong people are in power and the
wrong people will
seemingly continue to be in power and
there's nothing that anybody can do
so i actually was one of the first of
kind of my circle of friends to
venture out of the country and make the
decision to move out of the country
it was a time where you know people were
still a little bit optimistic there were
elections coming up again
there were some things to look forward
to but my mom didn't want to take the
risk and she was actually the one that
encouraged me
to apply for a scholarship in the us and
and to make the decision to move which
was very difficult
especially given that you know how i
said that
when you live in such a sheltered
environment stepping outside of that
kind of comfort zone is terrifying it
makes you feel really vulnerable and
and afraid i guess so i was 17 when i
moved
out of venezuela and it was tough
because at that time like i said we were
still optimistic that things could get
better so it almost felt like i was um
giving up
on my country i'm very patriotic about
my country so you know i'm assuming like
a lot of people are
when you grow up in a country you
develop emotions and sentiment
towards the place that you grew up that
gave you everything i felt like i was
giving up on my country and felt bad
for a little bit but then the country
just continued to trend downwards into
what it is today which is absolutely
awful and
20 times worse than what it was when i
left 10 years ago
where did you land when you first moved
to the us i landed in miami
it's actually a funny story i was so
upset that my mom convinced me to move
and we were in the shuttle at the
airport at the miami international
airport
and i was just crying hysterically like
if you
didn't know what was happening you could
have sworn that my mom was kidnapping me
or something
i was so mad maybe not mad at my mom but
mad at the situation
mad that i was forced to leave my
country matt that i
had it all i was a really good soccer
player i was the team captain of the
national team
i had a name for myself there and i just
felt like i was forced
out of my country and forced to start
over and it wasn't my decision
it wasn't the route that i really wanted
to take like i wanted to stay there with
my friends with my family
with my soccer team come down
in miami and then i went to san diego
that's where i wanted to or
initially i got into school san diego
beautiful place let's flash forward just
to not
continue sequentially so we're going to
bounce back and forth
can you please describe for people some
of
your records and at what body weights
those records were achieved so i guess
i'll speak of the most monumental ones
or
the most historic ones so i was the
first woman to deadlift
i guess four times my body weight first
at a powerlifting competition
and that was i weighed 120 pounds and i
debt lifted i guess
over or 500. then i beat that record
weighing
again 120 or 123. that lifted
545 pounds you don't really
know what your body is capable of until
you actually do it and
there's a lot of kind of limitations
that are placed upon yourself based on
what other people are doing
and so i remember the first time i
deadlifted 400 pounds when i said i was
gonna deadlift 500 pounds every
one thought it was crazy that it was
impossible that there's no way i could
do it at that body weight
and then look magical things happen and
and i trained really hard
obviously trained intelligently and was
able to
achieve things that no other woman had
ever been capable of doing
and what's interesting to me and i don't
know if maybe there's a name for this
phenomenon or something but
after i did that there were several
girls that were able to achieve that 500
pound
deadlift mark as soon as people see that
there's something that is humanly
possible it's almost like
it gives them the strength or the it
allows them to be able to chase
those same goals yeah it's like roger
bannister in the four-minute mile
same right exactly same story exactly
and yeah outside of that i've i've
broken i guess 25
world records in powerlifting in three
different weight classes
i've cut down all the way from 135
pounds all the way down to 114
broken squat deadlift and total world
records there
broken a few world records in the 123
class and then some in the 132 class i
have also that the highest uh deadlift
in that class as well
what are your other lifts what are some
of your other
personal bests personal records prs and
say bench squat or any other lift that
you want to mention my best squad is 510
pounds at 120
pounds body weight and a bench
uh 240 to 120 as well
sorry let's try to laugh it's just like
i've been having this year
so i may turn this into like a pro bono
uh
consulting session i'm 43 i've been
having this year where like all of these
injuries are cropping up i'm feeling
like
i'm feeling like an older version of
leonardo dicaprio and the revenant like
dragging one leg behind me like some
broken horse and i you know i'm
listening to these numbers and i'm like
you know i'm sitting in a pretty tall
building i should just throw myself off
oh my god
throw myself off the deck right now
these are just
insane numbers now let me tilt the
the microscope a bit because i want to
ask you and this might be a way of
exploring some of these lifts and
explaining what they mean to people
we know quite a few people in common one
of them you're probably closer to him
than i am but he was in
my last book tribe mentors ed cohn
so ed cohn could you describe for people
who ed cohn
is and what
what is most impressive about him to you
i think this will be a way of then
coming back to some of your achievements
and approaches
man ed is known as the greatest power
lifter of all time
he he has that he's earned the title
he's been given the title
by pretty much everyone within the
powerlifting community
and i think what separates him from
everyone else
is just how consistently he was able to
show up and perform at his best
throughout the years i don't know how
many years he competed maybe 20 years
which is
crazy anyone who's ever attempted to get
stronger anyone of any person who's
listening to this
just try training for more than two
years when progress starts slowing down
when you start coming into the gym and
feeling like crap and
not able to perform your best you start
accumulating injuries
and you know it takes years for you to
see even a
five pound increment in any of the lifts
just the amount of mental
fortitude mental strength that you have
to have in order to just keep showing up
and hoping that what you're doing is
taking you closer to your goals or
pushing you in the right direction
is is unbelievable you know i've spoken
to ed
extensively about his mindset and about
what some of his training theories were
in in his training methods and
he pretty much just said that he
i asked him if he ever stopped making
progress and he said no
he said anytime my progress would slow
down i would
go in and really take a look at what
areas of weaknesses
i had and i would tackle them with the
same intensity that i tackle
my on season or like the seasons where
you're preparing for a power lifting
meet
and he would repeat that over and over
and over again obviously look ed is not
from this world man like that guy
that is that is like the the pot calling
the kettle black
a bit i should also just say real
quickly no relation you are cohen
c-o-h-e-n he is
ed cohn c-o-a-n but yes he is
an alien for sure the resiliency his
body has and his ability to
just tolerate beating his body down with
weights is
remarkable it really is so he's a
specimen
i recall a few of the things he said to
me when we were
chatting and one was that he would
he would plan out his entire i want to
say
season or a year in advance knowing with
absolute certainty that he would be able
to make every
attempt and i thought that was
really thought provoking considering
that the way a lot of people train is
they may not even take notes at all but
they go into the gym and decide what
they're going to do maybe they have some
rough outline but they don't have that
type of programming
yeah he just laid out in advance he had
a top-down approach to training
he kind of like reverse engineered his
program so
he would say okay so if i want to
deadlift 700 pounds
that means that i have to be able to
deadlift seven or 650 for
three which means that i have to do 625
for five
and then he would reverse engineer from
there which i think is really
interesting
so you you and he seem to be
how should i put this designed for
obsessed with
specialists in the deadlift i mean ed ed
is known
for i i can't remember what the lift was
902 at two
200 or 190 or something something insane
and you have these ant like
multiples on your on your lifting you're
just a human
little little human female venezuelan
ant
and now there are many people who
we should also take a moment just to
explain the deadlift
for people so could you explain the
deadlift what that actually means
and then the competition deadlift let's
just say and then next
could you tell me what are some of the
things that distinguish
a person who trains and i'm just going
to leave weight classes out of this for
a minute because
it'll make it a little little complex
but people who say train
up to a deadlift of four or 500 pounds
versus those people who get
we could look at it as a multiple of
body weight but like someone who gets up
to 2x body weight versus someone who
gets to
three or four times body weight like
what are the differences in how they
approach the deadlift
the deadlift there's not much to it
there's a bar on the floor
and the goal is to pick it up until your
leg your knees and hips are locked out
all the way i think it's one of the most
impressive
feats of strength and i think uh
universally speaking like a lot
people consider that the ultimate test
of
strength that's why it's so celebrated
there's two
methods of deadlifting you can either
have a conventional style of deadlift
which is with your hands outside of your
feet and then there's the opposite which
is the sumo deadlift
where your hands are inside or within
your feet
and that's it as far as what the
deadlift is yeah so for a visual for
people if you imagine
like you said there is a a loaded bar
resting on the ground so it has plates
on either end you walk up to it if it's
conventional
stance then you're going to again this
is oversimplified but have
your feet just say roughly hip distance
apart and you're going to
almost squat down again this is very
simplified and grab the bar with your
your arms on the outsides of your knees
in the sumo stance your feet are going
to be turned out slightly they'll be
much further apart
and you'll almost look like you're doing
a really wide plie from
ballet when you go down to grab the bar
between your legs
hands under your shoulders roughly in
both cases
okay so then we have all these folks
doing god knows what
and eventually they muscle their way to
maybe
maybe maybe a 2x deadlift right but
perhaps
they're not approaching in a very
organized way and then you have people
who are able to do
significantly more two and a half three
times and you know then you get into the
rarefied air of doing what you do how do
people
make that leap crossing the chasm to
those higher weights what are the things
that are different
i think the main thing has to do with
its physics with leverage
you know if you see people some people
are really gifted
when it comes to proportions i think i'm
one of them i think that really
makes a difference when it comes to
being able to break that two three four
five times body weight marcus is your
leverages your
your proportions there's a guy i believe
it's in the usapl
who man he has a really odd
in terms of proportions looking body he
has a very short
extremely short torso and he has super
long
arms and when he locks out the deadlift
it just seems like the barbell
moves just a few inches off off the
ground
and i'm pretty sure that guy's done five
times body weight i'm pretty sure
you would have to fact-check me on that
some people it's genetics right some
people can train
so hard some people can train the exact
same way as edcon maybe have him as a
coach
and and never achieve half of what what
he achieved or never
never lift a quarter of how much ed
lifted and i think a big part of it is
is your proportions your leverages and
then when we get into genetics as well
muscle fiber type composition your
ability to learn new skills etc
just to kind of draw a circle around the
genetics certainly you have
genetics as a huge component like you
mentioned i mean you see a lot of
championship bench pressers at least in
the men's category with
who have a lot of girth right and the
distance the bar
travels is a real factor right so if you
can put in a huge arch and also have
a gigantic belly on you then it can be
very very helpful and
lift like the bench press or you have
someone like edcone
who is five foot six but
i've seen photographs of him putting his
hand against
the hands of nba players and they have
roughly the same sized hands right
huge hands yeah yeah so his ability to
hold a standard size bar
relative to his body weight is just
going to give him incredible
advantages but yeah i was just going to
say well
well i want you to continue because i
i've had too much caffeine but i i'd
love to
i'd love to draw a circle around the
genetics and recognize those for being
as important as they are but then to
talk about not the attributes which
people can't mimic
like they're not going to get a muscle
fiber transplant but
some of the technologies and approaches
and programming and
the methodologies that say you've used
i'd love to talk about but what were you
going to say
yeah i think that they're more
specialized you know how people
what's that saying hard work beats
talent when talon doesn't work hard
okay yeah that's saying i'm really bad
at memorizing sayings and quotes
but you know what i mean i do when it
comes to powerlifting
you can want it all you want you can
work as hard as you
want but because it's such a specialized
sport
having the right attributes for the
sport is even more important so for
example
say you want to be a i don't know a
football player there's many positions
within football
that might be in line with what your
current skills and abilities are
and you might actually be able to out
work your way
into a pro team by gaining more speed by
being stronger by being able to cut
sharper by
i don't know you know you can gain an
advantage in so many different
areas or categories within the skills
that you need to succeed in football
whereas
in powerlifting there's really not much
you know you either have the capability
to get stronger or you don't
and you either have the proportions to
be able to move the bar
in the most efficient way or you don't
true fact
as kelly starrett would say but
let's all right let me make this even
more concrete so a few years ago i did
a a triple with 475 or so
on a uh trap bar so a
hex bar depending on on what term people
want to apply
that at the time at least training over
say a six month or
year-long period doing mostly just pulls
to the knees
based on a program popularized by a
sprint coach named barry ross that was
basically my ceiling right and i
probably weighed
180 at the time so i'm not winning any
any multiple awards
but i have very very small hands my
proportions are not really built
i wouldn't say terribly well for the
deadlift but i also didn't have
a coach i didn't have any real eye to
the detail of training for the deadlift
so if i came to you i show up with like
a hobo stick and a little
satchel with my lunch box at your gym
and i'm just like please
save me make me a better deadlifter how
would you start
i would start by looking at your form
looking at your technique
and seeing if there's anything there
that i can improve you know
things like bringing your feet width in
maybe changing your
hand position improving the angle of
your torso
maybe looking at your starting position
i would start there
and obviously like programming is the
biggest factor to look at as well
just how whether or not you're uh
implementing progressive overload into
your training
how hard are you training are you going
to failure there's
many many variables that we can look at
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show
this episode is brought to you by
athletic greens i get asked
all the time what i would take if i
could only take one supplement
the answer is invariably athletic greens
i view it as all-in-one nutritional
insurance
i recommended it in fact in the four
hour body this is more than ten years
ago
and i did not get paid to do so with
approximately 75 vitamins
minerals and whole foods sourced
ingredients you'd be very hard-pressed
to find a more nutrient-dense and
comprehensive formula on the market it
has multivitamins
multi-mineral greens complex probiotics
and prebiotics for gut health and
immunity formula digestive enzymes
adaptogens and much more i usually take
it
once or twice a day just to make sure
i've covered my bases
if i miss anything i'm not aware of of
course i focus on nutrient-dense meals
to begin with that's the basis
but athletic greens makes it easy to get
a lot of nutrition when whole foods
aren't readily available
from travel packets i always have them
in my bag
when i'm zipping around and right now
athletic greens is giving my audience
that's you guys
a special offer on top of their
all-in-one formula which is a free
vitamin d supplement with your first
subscription purchase many of us are
deficient in vitamin d
which is usually produced in our bodies
from sun exposure so particularly in the
winter months adding a vitamin d
supplement to your daily routine
is a great option for additional immune
support so make an investment in your
health today and try the ultimate
all-in-one wellness bundle
support your immunity gut health and
energy by visiting athleticgreens.com
tim you'll receive up to a year's supply
of vitamin d for free with your first
subscription purchase
again that's athleticgreens.com tim
if you want to get into the training
methodologies portion of the
of the question that you asked a little
bit ago yeah let's let's get into it
let's just start with one factory
throughout there do you train to failure
do you train to failure
or do you train a failure often you do
yes
so i come from an olympic weightlifting
background
i trained most of my i guess i did
olympic lifting for about four years
and it was mainly bulgarian style
lifting i don't know if you're familiar
with that but that just involves
daily maxes is what you call daily maxis
so obviously
the amount you can lift in every session
is going to vary based on just your
nervous system readiness how tired you
are how well you recovered from the
previous sessions
but ultimately what you're trying to do
is lift as much as you can
in any one particular session was this
started in venezuela or in the us
it was here so my olympic weightlifting
coach is cuban
and their training philosophies come
from eastern europe as well
camilo camilo
that was kind of my initial introduction
into
strength training i kind of like picked
up certain things from that and also
learned
why they might not be the best
essentially
people in bulgaria russia the system
to find the best athletes is a little
bit different than it is here
basically you know they're they're
putting a lot of people through
extremely rigorous training and the
people that you see succeed are very few
you know i'm talking about
0.0001 of all the kids that they put
through these training programs
make it through so it's like you either
thrive under those conditions or you
break
but you know hell week for buds training
navy seals yes so it works but it's not
it's not the best way and i don't think
that
i don't think that a lot of people are
built to withstand that
amount of beating the way that i kind of
modified that
combined my experience with i guess my
my
academic training which is i have a
background in exercise physiology and
i have my doctorate in physical therapy
i've been able to implement a little bit
from you know practical with what the
science says so in terms of
training to failure there's there's a
lot of controversy
when it comes to what the minimal
effective
dose of training is there's pretty much
two separate camps one that is all about
accumulating volume just doing very low
not very but low load high volume style
training
in hopes of sparing your body your
tissues
and decreasing your injury risk and then
there's the other one
that's the bulgarian russian that goes
all the way to the other extreme which
is
if your goal is to get stronger then you
have to
train in a way that's conducive to the
adaptations that you're
trying to elicit like if you're trying
to get better at your one mile
you're trying to beat your one mile run
you're gonna run
one mile often so same principle here if
you're trying to
get a better one red max squad you gotta
be
squatting to a you know daily max or a
really high intensity often
and where my training philosophies fall
is somewhere down the middle
and it's the same way with pretty much
everything in my life i try not to
swing in one particular direction i try
to stay unbiased and i try to kind of
learn a little bit from everyone from
every from every camp
and then apply it to myself and to the
people that i coach so
as far as the way that i train and coach
other people it's a mix
could you give us an example of a
competition
training split for you and then we can
just walk through
some of the what some of the workouts
look like so in preparation for a
competition
you essentially break down your training
into four
blocks you have your general your gpp
your general physical preparedness
phase where you're essentially just
accumulating volume
improving just your aerobic capacity
your ability to
do multiple reps so this is a high
volume face
then you move into a more specialized
block where you start getting rid of
all the fluff in your programs you start
decreasing the amount of cardio you do
the amount of exercise variability and
you start
increasing the frequency of the main
lifts so you start
squatting benching and dead lifting more
because those are the three lifts that
are tested
in competition then you go into the
intensification phase
which is where you start increasing the
intensity so you start getting into the
85 90 95 100 of
the three main lifts and do nothing
else other than that maybe a little bit
of core a little bit of back
just because you have to start focusing
and hyper specializing more into those
three things that you're going to be
tested on
then you go through a two week deload
period where you
pretty much cut everything that you've
been doing in half by 50
and then you got your competition and
it's funny because when you get to your
competition it's like
you're the strongest you've ever been
you know after going through that
process
but you're also the least human that
you've ever been as well
like going up a flight of stairs is
excruciatingly
tiring you know because you're so
specialized
yeah yeah you do condition in every
other area like you move like a
like you're made out of tinfoil like
you're made out of metal and
seriously it's awful oh you were strong
[ __ ] so
there's that
oh yeah my friend mark bell
you may have met before he's hilarious
talking about that
you know going through his fat and
skinny phases and when he's big
having trouble tying his shoes it's
really a high degree of specialization
and then if you look at
let's just take you could pick any of
those phases but let's just say maybe
the intensification phase
what does a week of training look like
how are things spread out personally
i like squatting two or three times per
week deadlifting
one time per week and benching three to
four times per week
so in the intensification phase you're
basically staying within
nothing more than five reps so i tend to
when i'm squatting five reps so okay
let's make it easier so say monday
wednesday friday i'm squatting i'm doing
five reps and three reps then two reps
on those days
and so the reps go down but the
intensity goes up as the week goes by
if i'm following that split then i'll
likely dead lift closer to my
least intense squat day so i'll likely
deadlift within the beginning of the
week if i'm gonna split it that way so
that i'm
i'm not so tired by the end of the week
and can actually see what i'm capable of
doing in the deadlift
and then bench i usually keep it a lot
higher volume
even during an intensification phase i
think that
especially for women because we i don't
know what the phenomenon is i actually
want to get into that because
i don't have an answer but something
about the bench press and woman
we just make progress a lot slower and i
think in terms of absolute strength
we we rarely reach it so we can get away
with
pretty much anything we're doing higher
volume lower volume more sets more reps
whatever it is
and it doesn't seem to like impact the
way that we recover from these sessions
if we're looking at the whole picture
you've mentioned
longevity in sport in the context of
edcone
competing for some ungodly number of
years 20 years
and how you contend with plateaus or
very slow progress
injuries and certainly he's no stranger
to injuries and
when you have a leg buckle under 900
pounds or
thousand pounds i mean things don't
always
you don't always just jog away from one
of those
how has rehab or prehab
been included or thought of as a
component
of your training and your i suppose
athletic life in general
i'm a little bit adverse to those terms
uh because i think they're they're often
times
used out of context and for their wrong
purposes
especially by medical professionals
physical therapists chiropractors
but i think it's look rehab prehab are
essentially training
so it falls into periodization it falls
into how are you organizing your
training
to make sure you're actually going
through the appropriate phases to set
you up
to be able to withstand so that your
tissues essentially can tolerate the
amount of load that you're
placing on them this is something that i
actually love talking about is
why do injuries happen you know most
people
think that they can prevent injuries
through stretching or they can prevent
injuries through doing rehab or
corrective exercises
and that's nothing more
than someone trying to position
themselves in a way that makes them seem
like they know something that you don't
positioning themselves as if you know
they're some sort of like
i always say this the sherlock holmes of
of injuries like they can
pinpoint the exact area of weakness that
you have that will lead to an injury
and that type of thinking is overly
simplistic and it's
outdated you know we like to think that
we have the answers for everything and
maybe that happens because humans want
to know the exact cause of things and
then maybe healthcare practitioners feel
pressured to have to give this very
specific and concrete answers when in
reality
injuries are multifactorial and more
often than not
identifying the exact source
of an injury or why it happened or what
tissue is injured
is very very difficult the best way that
i can explain this is
injuries not most times always
happen when the load that you're
imparting on tissues
exceed their tolerance so it's a the way
i i visualize it it's a two-part
equation
we have load on one side you have
tolerance on one side so it becomes
about
managing external forces and building
internal tolerance
to those forces so when i talk about
load
uh it's everything i spoke about uh how
you organize your training
you know whether you're going through
the right faces uh
and you're progressively increasing the
amount of weight that you're lifting to
allow your tissues
to be able to withstand those forces
then on the same topic of load
say that you start having an area or a
tissue that's
that's starting to get irritated how
well you have to think about
how are these forces being dispersed
within your body
you know maybe the way that you're
lifting say
up people have a side joint pain s-i
joint
you just that's sacroiliac joint right
so could you just
tell people where that is if they want
to locate it on their own bodies
so your sacroiliac joint is pretty much
on your hip so if
you were to put your hands on your hip
with your thumbs facing backwards it's
like
essentially where your thumb ends up
naturally when you put your hands on
your waist
it's a common area that gets hurt when
you're lifting weights
uh but anyway so what i'm saying is
sometimes when that happens it's also a
matter of you know where are those
forces being dispersed within your body
and why
is that one area taking up most of that
load
so a corrective exercise is essentially
figuring out
what exercises you can do that would
spare the irritated tissue
that's what a corrective exercise is and
then as far as increasing the tolerance
then again
that just goes you gotta reduce workload
or modify workload so that your tissues
can actually have time to
repair from your previous training days
and be able to continue repairing
healing and then doing it all over again
that is the essence of injuries and
anyone that tells you
anything more complex or that tries to
tell you that
your multifidus is irritated or is
inflamed or that you're
whatever like people just get so um so
caught up on just these details that
matter very little when it comes to
creating a plan of care for a patient
let's use a
let's use a real or hypothetical example
but have you
battled with say low back injury or
other injuries that we can use as a case
study
yeah oh my god that is uh that's the
that was my inspiration for writing my
book
if you could talk to what you have done
following an injury and how it differs
from
what might be common
approaches i think that would be very
helpful for people
so i'll give you guys a little
background on the type of injury i had
and then i'll get into some of the
things that i did
to get out of it essentially i was in my
first year of
physical therapy school the first time
that i had
a seemingly career ending injury for
some reason you know
we attach so much emotion to a
low back injury i'm assuming it's mostly
cultural and societally based it's just
the fear surrounding back injuries
that's been perpetuated by
healthcare professionals and doctors
based on many many things that i
actually talk about in my book
the first time i remember it was chronic
in nature in the sense that
it was just getting increasingly worse
every training session
and i guess any high level performer
athlete would relate to this in the
sense that you
at the beginning when you start
experiencing aches and pains you try to
ignore them try to convince yourself
that it's not as bad as it seems
and you just try to look for ways to
continue training you think it's part of
the game
you know you think that no pain no gain
these are all things that are so deeply
ingrained
in our beliefs as athletes that we have
a hard time taking a step back because
we are afraid
of exposing our weaknesses or we're
afraid of
quitting or we're afraid of of our coach
thinking that we don't want it enough
and so we just tend to ignore the
signals that our body is sending us
so that's exactly what i did even and
what's funny is that even you know i had
a pretty solid understanding about the
human body and injuries and how this all
works
and even then i was just so uh it wasn't
such
denial of what i was experiencing that i
just
essentially kept increasing the amount
of painkillers that i was taking
and didn't change anything else kept
showing up to training kept training
as hard as i was before just started
maybe tying my belt a little bit tighter
you wearing my belt a little bit sooner
and like i said increasing the amount of
painkillers i was taking
and it was a recipe for disaster i spent
several months training
in excruciating pain to the point where
it started affecting my activities of
daily living
you know i was having a hard time
putting my socks on or putting my shoes
on
remember waking up in the morning just
so stiff
like i looked like i was 120 years old i
could barely move i i needed to have
assistance doing many things and what's
crazy is that i still
thought that it was normal i'm like i'm
a power lifter i'm ex i'm expected
to feel this way and that just led
to this one lift
one time i remember i unwrapped the bar
i was going for a
three rep max personal best
and i unwrapped the bar i felt kind of
more wobbly than normal in my low back i
lowered the bar down
and at the bottom of the lift i just
felt kind of like a
like a snap on my back or kind of yeah
just something
really wrong so i tossed the bar onto
the pins fell down onto the floor
and laid there for 45 minutes without
being able to move without being able to
take my belt off
nothing just completely just paralyzed
by pain
and obviously you know at that point was
i
actually no you would think that i would
take a step back then i actually took
i think i took a week off and then went
to uh to san diego to compete in the
biggest powerlifting competition of the
year
i actually called stubborn i know i
called ed
when that happened and i called mark
bell called both of them and i asked him
what they would do
and i asked him if if they have competed
injured
and they both said yes so i was like man
you know if if they can do it i can do
it like there's
i'm a week out of a competition yeah i
got really hurt but
whatever you know i'll just i'll suck it
up and then
and i'll rest afterwards kind of thing
so i did it i competed it was the worst
competition of my life i bummed out
in an international stage it was pretty
embarrassing
bombed out means you did you didn't make
your attempts exactly
and that was that was my wake-up call
that that was the moment when i was like
okay like i
i actually have to do something i have
to do something to
to fix this or to to get out of pain and
that's when my
quest for figuring out low back injuries
came in i had obviously had access to a
lot of
seemingly great physical therapists
given that i was in a top 10
nationwide program for physical therapy
and i was able to ask for different
opinions
from a lot of people and what was
surprising to me was that i was
constantly getting
different answers they didn't seem to
have
really anything in common and it was
just so evident to me
that no one really knew what they were
talking about really like i would just
get a different diagnosis
every time i would go to talk to a
different person i got
no consistency in terms of their
responses
so imagine that right like i'm the
patient in this case and i'm going to
what i would consider kind of the most
powerful figures of authority that i had
access to
professors that i look up to professors
that are phds that are doing research
maybe some that were
biomechanists some that are spine
specialists and still
i was not getting one i wasn't getting
any relief and two i wasn't
again i wasn't getting any consistency
in their answers so that's when i
started reading a ton about it and
obsessing about it to the point where i
thought
i should write a book to help clear up
some of the confusion that
not only clinicians are experiencing but
obviously
patience and i think part of that
problem
lies and i'm lucky in the sense that i
practice physical therapy in the
non-traditional
sense because i don't see patients i
spend most of my time reading research
which again is is one part of of
evidence-based practice
i guess i practice on myself and on
people that are around me
most clinicians between patients and
and paperwork and all the things that
they have to do in a day they don't
really have time
to dive into the research like i did you
know
this book took two years to write and we
pretty much
go back 5 000 years to understand
where our beliefs come from and how
science has evolved
and how pain science has impacted some
of
their recommendations and how how it's
changed over the years
so that hopefully we can have a more
unified approach when it comes
to back rehab essentially well i have a
million questions
and i want to make sure we offer some
specifics to folks who may
want to get some some tactical
advice realizing that you don't see
patients but
i want to take this in a few different
directions
so the the first is
your experience with this injury
paralytic on the ground
in pain you compete bomb out certainly
i would say didn't do yourself any
favors with the back
by doing that what were some of the
things
insights or training approaches that
ended up really making a difference for
you
especially with the lack of diagnosis
because i think a lot of people
listening
or lack of consensus in diagnosis right
so i'm looking at some notes
from your book which i don't think are
verbatim but they're
really important i think just to
underscore for
folks so there's there's one paragraph
that really jumped out at me and i'm
just going to read this here
medicine is a science of uncertainty in
an art of probability
in other words you know the oscillator
maximum 3000 years into an effort to
unlock the mystery of pain continues to
produce more noise and signal there's
still no discernible cause for back pain
and 95 to 99 of cases yet it continues
to be the leading cause of disability
worldwide
so this is a very depressing paragraph
for a lot of people but i want to break
it into two pieces number one is that
when people say science proves or
studies
show you should always look at the
source material because
science or i should say more accurately
really good research and studies
really just indicate the probability of
something being true
and so you have to really understand
that you cannot say definitively
or you should be very cautious of saying
definitively this proves this
you have a an inflamed
sartorius muscle and that's referring to
your left shoulder which is causing your
right testicle to swell which is causing
your right eye to hurt
right but you hear that kind of [ __ ] all
the time and it's like
wow okay i had no idea that that uh that
cascade was so powerful
and there are good pts and very good
doctors out there
but you should be aware of complicating
to profit
right or if a medical professional is
aware that you are shopping for a
certain diagnosis eventually you will
find someone who is willing to give you
the diagnosis that you think you have
so you have to be very cautious but
breaking it into this so that's just
overview comment on the limitations of
what people consider science
even when it comes to scientific
research there's actually studies and
i don't have the name of it here but
there's actually studies that prove that
more often than not the results of a
study
are likely incorrect or
non-generalizable
so yeah it's the replication crisis it's
the ability to replicate studies and the
outcomes of studies
is abysmally difficult exactly exactly
that's a whole separate thing like it's
such a bummer we need more money in
funding replication studies but there's
so little career and status incentive
for academics to
focus their own personal resources on
replication
that we end up in this really gnarly
situation but let's jump to the second
part which is more personalized for a
lot of people listening that is
there's no discernible cause for back
pain in 95 to 99
of cases so a lot of people listening to
what you said and hearing that will say
well
[ __ ] if you can't figure out what's
causing it
how can you possibly fix it right so
then let's use that as a leaping point
to what did you do that helped what are
the things that you
ended up finding really had a valuable
bang for the buck
so let's go back just briefly on
our terminology the words that we're
using so when you say let's do it
what what can we do to fix it i don't
like when people even
when people say that because that
implies that something's broken
yeah no whip my ass into shape i want
you to tell me better words to use
because like the words you know the
limits of our words are the limits of
our world right so
like strike that from the record yeah i
would just say
how can we decrease your symptoms or how
can we
decrease your discomfort there's nothing
to fix especially when it comes to like
i said 95
of those cases you know we're moving
further away from the mechanistic
views of the sources of back pain so all
this means is
we come from a background where
when it comes to the neurophysiology of
pain we used to tie
the severity of a symptom to the amount
of damage
in our body and with the evolution of
pain science
especially now that it's that it's kind
of permeating more into
the physical therapy realm and then and
fitness and sports
now we understand that pain isn't
directly tied to tissue damage so
we essentially we are overly relying on
diagnostic tests like the mri or the
x-rays
because it's essentially it gives you a
really good picture of what's inside
but it completely takes out of the
equation the subjectivity of pain
so we know just based on research that
or based on studies
that 37 of 20 year olds
have asymptomatic degenerative disc
disease and
disc herniations those numbers bump all
the way up to
84 and 94 for people over 80 years old
so it's just that what you see on the
inside is
a better way to look at it is as just
wrinkles on the inside
things that happen naturally from aging
and we need to stop
to detach the emotions that we have with
i guess those images because they don't
really tell you much about what the
person is experiencing
that was another line from the notes on
your book that i
highlighted which is pain isn't a
reliable sign of damage
exactly which is very counter-intuitive
right because you cut your finger when
you're cutting carrots
with a knife and you're like cut hurt
pain cause
effect and and a story right but it's
just not that simple
no of course and like i said look
there's there's two views there's a
mechanistic
and then there's the pain science so
again i fall somewhere in the middle
i would never say that there's no way
that that nothing's going on
underneath your skin you know i'm sure
that there's there's some cases where
there's an
actual structure that's getting
irritated that somehow got
hurt and that is the source of pain but
in 95
of cases we really don't know what the
source is and and i don't think that
should be discouraging i think
that should be encouraging because you
know now you can relate
your pain experience to most cases it's
always good when you fall within the
lines of the probability and not when
you're outside
that's when you're in trouble because
you're a special case you don't want to
be a special case
well you're right you said you're in the
middle you're like the goldilocks of
powerlifting and pain science
you're always in the middle so so let's
get into some specifics i think this is
this is super fascinating so we're not
going to use
fix we're going to talk about decreasing
symptoms of pain
right i think what you also said is that
like hey with if you're
within one standard deviation of the
middle that's actually really good news
if it's
if you're in the group that is 90 to 99
of cases having no discernible cause
that's actually not
necessarily a bad thing if you're like
three five sigma out
and you're missing 10 vertebrae then you
really have a major issue going on
exactly so let's talk about
some of the actions you took or things
you stopped
that made a real difference for you in
terms of this is something
an assessment it's something that you
can do on your own
is instead of focusing on
what needs fixing or what is the failing
structure
you can focus on things that are a lot
more actionable
in your assessment or your therapist or
whoever is doing it for you or yourself
and the things that i look at are first
directional preference
so essentially what that means is are
you flexion or
extension intolerance so does it hurt
when you bend forward or does it hurt
when you bend backwards
that's the first thing that you need to
uh figure out and you'll know
and this is for overall back pain or
lower back pain
what type of pain are we talking about
like how does it present this is more
specific to low back pain but it
okay directional preference it would
literally apply to any injury does it
hurt when you bend your knee or when you
extend your knee
does it hurt when you rotate your neck
to the right or when you rotate your
neck to the left so
it's just kind of like you're checking
in with yourself to see
what are the positions that increase
your symptoms and what are the positions
that decrease your symptoms that's
essentially all that it is
then within direction there's also uh
compression versus shear especially when
it comes to the low back
so compression you can do an easy test
just by sitting on a chair and
you put your hands underneath the chair
and you push yourself
your buttocks towards the chair creating
compression
so are you intolerant to compression or
is it more sheer so
bending forward say with a with a light
uh object on your hands
farther away from your body does that
increase your pain more
so just checking in with yourself to
gain more understanding about the things
that
improve your pain or decrease your pain
then
what are some of the postures that
increase the painful sensations
is it sitting down is it standing up is
it walking a lot is it not walking a lot
is it running
is it lifting is it you know what are
you doing in the day today that
exacerbates your symptoms
and finally figuring out what your
current load tolerance is especially if
you're a lifter i guess this doesn't
apply if you're not a lifter but
if you are a lifter you have to figure
out what your
margin of error is when it comes to your
injury
you know when are when do your symptoms
start appearing is it at 50
is it at 60 70 80 90 when do they start
appearing
and during the time where your symptoms
seem to be
heightened then that's a good time for
you to stay underneath that margin of
error and stay
underneath that pain threshold so you
can
essentially teach your body how to get
out of pain do you have an opinion
of as another point of reference
healing back pain the mind body
connection by john sarno
do you have any opinion of that book
comes up a lot
in conversations about back pain do you
have any commentary i actually haven't
read it
i'll have to get back to you okay no
problem it's a tbd i just want to add
sort of a small bit of commentary
about pain because i like a lot of
people was very
mechanistic for the majority of my life
something hurts something must be broken
or torn or strained let me find that
problem and fix that problem and pain
will disappear
and i had chronic chronic severe pain
in my left mid back for
many years and i i think it was
initially
caused by you know an acute incident
specifically a
closet fell off a moving truck and i
caught
the closet which was like i don't know
100 plus pounds really
large and it twisted my torso to one
side it was a bad bad injury
but that pain then recurred for many
many years
and i didn't experiment with and i'm not
advising this to people listening but
so that i could speak to the experience
intelligently
from first-hand experience did a series
of five ketamine
infusions intravenously at one point and
the intention was not at all to look at
chronic pain
but it is used
for in some cases chronic pain that
didn't mean anything to me at the time
because i hadn't done the reading
and i came away from my experience past
that week
overall not feeling like i could
recommend ketamine therapy outside of
someone with
acute suicidal ideation where i think it
does have real applications
but about a week later i realized that
my
mid back pain had completely vanished
and
it did not come back this is like a year
and a half
now and counting and it just there are
theories around
ketamine's effects on nmda receptors and
so on
that account for this but it's thought
to almost provide a like a hard reset
for some of these pain pathways and
again i'm using terminology that
perhaps i shouldn't but like that you
can in some way
paste over these ruts that have been
created in terms of
repetitive circuits that cause these
experiences subjectively of pain but the
idea that i could have
an infusion a couple of days and then
walk away and have this pain just
vanish even though it is in the short
term an anesthetic was so mind-blowing
to me that there would be durability to
that effect
so it's caused me to think about pain
completely
differently yeah that is super
interesting i actually would love to
read more about
ketamine specifically for persistent
pain but it just goes to show
just how powerful our brains are right
like
if you're experiencing persistent pain
our bodies adapt to literally
anything so it would make no sense that
you have something
broken or something that needs fixing
for for two plus years even for more
than six months it's already a stretch
so it just goes to show how and you know
in your case was the ketamine infusion
but
anything that breaks the pain cycle is
positive in terms of uh delivering a
more positive response to
to pain because essentially you start
forming these habits that are tied to
your experience with pain it's not more
of a sensation anymore is
about the perception we have and the
experiences that we have
that literally alter the way that we
feel and think
and sense threat from the environment
so we were talking about your assessment
right the the
general parameters for doing an
assessment and you know i'm sitting here
with a couple of injuries right now
thinking about this like my wrist and my
left hip and all this you know
sort of like you know ate an orange and
went to bed and woke up with like a neck
injury kind of thing i don't know what
the hell's going on but
the point is we're talking about an
assessment after an injury
for people who are thinking to
themselves you know i would like to make
an
investment in making my body more
resilient so that the likelihood of
having a back injury is lower are there
any recommendations
that you would have for those people any
often neglected
types of strengthening or anything
really
that that come to mind i mean according
to the literature it's not so much
strengthening it's not either a
stability thing
that's another hole that we can get into
but i mean the best way i guess to
prevent any injury
back injuries is endurance so there's a
bunch of studies
done on construction workers and another
form
form of labor workers and they
determined essentially that
the ones with the most back endurance
and they measured this
via doing hold back extensions so how
long can you hold the back extension so
it's not necessarily for strength but
more so
how long can you hold us a certain
posture and then duration yeah
yeah so they determined that those with
the most back endurance were the most
worth the most resilient to back
injuries
and then it goes back to positions
postures
and movements that you practice so
a lot of people for example when people
want to get into running
running is accessible to everyone right
you just put a pair of sneakers on and
you go out and run
the thing that happens with that is that
you didn't appropriately expose yourself
to the mileage that you were gonna do or
the terrain
and so making sure that there's an
appropriate again an appropriate
progression
in what you're doing and you're
practicing those specific
movements those are going to be the
movements that are safe for you so
there's also research studies done where
you change
the way that people lift things so again
this was
i think it was construction workers
again where have you seen how they lift
like they have like their back rounded
and they're
picking up super heavy stuff in their
form quote-unquote
looks bad because we have this idea of
what good form is versus what bad form
is
that is totally arbitrary
based on i don't know what who said they
say people love to say
they say that's bad form i don't know
who they is but
essentially you know these people have
trained those positions those
postures those movements that way for
their entire life therefore
those are the positions that they are
the strongest in so
when it comes to modifying the way that
you lift or the way that you
pick up things or the way that you pick
up your baby or the way
you don't need to move like anyone else
you need to move like yourself whatever
you've been doing for a long time
that hasn't given you problems then
that's the way that you should continue
moving
yeah just a quick side note on the
form and you know they the illuminati of
the internet
who are like that's bad form i remember
and again i'm i'm talking out my ass
because i'm such a
junior varsity tourist when it comes to
any type of of strength
training but i'm a fan of strength
training
i try not to have too strong an opinion
about anything because i'm not qualified
but i remember the first time i saw
anna maybe pronouncing his name
incorrectly but constantine's
constantinops yes
deadlifting raw with a rounded back
setup
how crazy and right and he has a rounded
back setup for anybody
everybody should look this guy up he is
[ __ ]
i mean he's a superhero unbelievable
no belt no belt no belt and he's
he's just a complete beast and i don't
know how much
he can deadlift it's just like 420 plus
kilos
i mean he's which is you know raw with
that belt
but he sets up and he rounds his back
and so
you see that and you see him clearly as
this like master
technician of the deadlift and there are
all these millions of variations that he
also uses in training
and you're like okay who's going to tell
this guy that he's lifting incorrectly
no yeah yeah because we have this this
obsession with not rounding when we bend
forward
again one of those beliefs that have
been perpetuated over the years
coming from probably someone uh
interpreting a research paper
incorrectly
that is a very advanced deadlifting
technique that he developed
he skillfully developed throughout the
years in order to
make that position his strongest
position and the least likely position
for him to get hurt
now the obsession of like keeping your
back straight when you dead lift is
kind of silly because even when you
can't
observe that there's rounding in the
lower back
your spinal segments are at about 60 to
70 percent
inflection even when you're not
seeing any flexion happening when your
back is in quote unquote neutral your
back is bent
your spinal segments are already they've
changed in the the angles that they're
in they're they're already flexing
so there's nothing necessarily
inherently wrong with that
there's no instability going on you
because
essentially what is stability that was
that's funny that is what got me into
this whole topic
people talking about low back stability
you got to improve stability stability
stability of the segments
that was something that was so hammered
in our brains in physical therapy school
that i had to go back and
see what the whole what the fuzz was
about when it came to that
but essentially we need to understand
the differences in concepts between
stability and robustness when it comes
to back pain so that we can understand
essentially what their recommendations
would be
in terms of definitions robustness and i
like to
bring the analogy of comparing an oak
tree to a willow tree
so in terms of robustness is your
ability to cope with disturbances
in your environment so an oak tree will
be a lot more robust
than a willow tree when wind blows
onto it versus stability is just the
ability of a system to
return to normal after a disturbance
so the notion that
back pain or people who get hurt
deadlifting
or doing anything lack stability is is
unfounded because
as biological beings we have the
capability
to either up regulate or down regulate
the amount of tension
that is in our muscles at any given time
in proportion to the task that we are
doing so the amount of stability that
you need to
lay on your couch is different than the
amount of stability that you need when
you're lifting something up
not to mention it's difficult to measure
like no one knows how much stability you
need
or anything like that so we are capable
of strengthening and stabilizing
any position as long as is the position
that we're training if that makes sense
yeah that makes sense let me ask a
question i think you're going to hate
if you don't mind go ahead
you're going to be like oh this this
[ __ ] guy
all right so i recall this must have
been around 2008 2009
um i was probably
for the sake of simplicity say the
fittest and certainly the strongest that
i've been
in the last 10 years or so and i felt
very
resilient very robust in terms of
injury prevention i just did not get
injured a lot
despite doing a lot of training at the
time
and it's so difficult maybe impossible
to say
or identify single causes and effects
but nonetheless i had
at the time i had quite a bit of
interaction with gray cook
who has the functional movement screen
and so on
and i was using turkish getup single leg
deadlift
and chop and lift quite a bit and so he
uses the turkish getup as a diagnostic
tool he also uses it as a
corrective tool uh maybe that's the
right way to phrase it but i found that
i found these exercises to be
extremely helpful for kind of checking a
lot of boxes at once
and in terms of like time invested and
benefits
are there any exercises or types of
training
that you would put in that bucket for
yourself
i think part of the reason why you
experienced a positive
where you had a positive experience with
those movements
by implementing them into your existing
training has to do with
movement variability so what happens
when we look at people who are hurt
one of the things that jumps out the
most is the lack of movement
options that they have lack of movement
variability so the more hurt that you
are the less
movement options you have so essentially
you're expanding your movement
vocabulary
by incorporating movements that
challenge
you in different planes you know your
ability to
resist forces that are coming different
ways you know by holding a kettlebell
in the overhead position the chop that's
working on the transverse plane you're
working on your your rotators your
spinal stabilizers
so i think the reason why that worked
for you was essentially because you
increased your movement vocabulary and
you were giving your body
more options for movement where it felt
non-threatened and it felt safe so
almost any movement has the capability
to do that and that's why i emphasize
the importance of
having a gpp a general physical
preparedness phase to
any program and that's something that
really gets lost in over specialized
sports like powerlifting and olympic
weightlifting is that people think they
have to be doing squat bench and
deadlift all the time
and don't find time or don't find
or or ignore the fact that they have to
include
other movements in order to maintain
their longevity and
in order to kind of boost their own
tissue tolerance and
their ability to remain injury free well
it's true outside of powerlifting too
right i mean if you take someone who has
any type of repetitive
movement could be tennis if you're just
a recreational tennis player
and sort of amateur which almost
everyone is going to be
and you're like hitting in a very
comfortable plane of motion with your
four-handed back end and then
you're you're limiting your exercise to
that and then one day you have this
heated scrimmage with a friend and you
get thrown out of that
normal plane of motion if you're not
supplementing that with
additional colors on the palette
right in the form of some type of
general physical preparedness then
there's a decent chance you're going to
get injured beautiful
right exactly um and i say that with
confidence because that's
i think what just happened to me
but then that goes to show that that no
one you know
that there's no magic exercise you know
i love talking about the mcgill big
three
so for anyone who doesn't know stewart
mcgill is one of the
most well-known authors when it comes to
low back pain and research
and a lot of people kind of put these
three exercises on on a pedestal and
view him as this guru because
somehow the bird dog the dead bug and
the side plank
became the best way to cure all back
pain
but in another thing wait hold on one
second so
the bird dog i know people can look it
up we're not going to get into it
side plank i know what is the what is
the dead bug
that sounds like something i'd be really
good at so so literally
i mean how how you would encounter a
dead bug when they're on their back
and they're like flailing their arms in
the air that's what doing a dead bug
looks like
you just like stick your arms and legs
straight up in the air while you're on
your back yeah and so you alternate
you know right arm back let a left leg
out and then alternate back and forth
okay okay
and that's that's the thing right like i
always like to understand
why so when i first learned about those
movements i'm like
okay i mean these provide me with relief
but why is it because these are some
magical movements
or you know what is going on here and
that i think the assumption a lot of
people make is that that improves
core stability because they assume that
that's the missing link
and that's again that's dangerous
because it goes back to
perpetuating that fear that people have
about their spines and it leads to
people being extremely
overprotective in their strategy so what
actually happens with these three
exercises the dead bug the bird dog
and the side plank is that the reason
why they
decrease pain symptoms is twofold the
first thing
is you're essentially providing a
positive movement experience
again if you're having an acute bout of
back pain or if
or if you've been in pain for a while
it's about finding a position that
doesn't increase your pain symptoms and
the other one is a very well documented
phenomenon called
exercise induced analgesia which is
basically
you know when you're contracting a
muscle isometrically
there's muscle spindles and
chemoreceptors in
within your muscle that send signals to
the brain to down regulate the pain
signal so
it provides you with a temporary
reduction
in pain symptoms so it's not that
they're magical it's just
that they work based on these two
mechanisms not because they're improving
stability not because
you're unstable and now you're stable
not because it's magical
but because of these reasons so same
same with with those three movements
that you were doing by great cook
yeah any any really good doctor
i respect in the
large group of doctors i've met most of
which i think are way over their skis in
terms of confidence
the the best doctors and the best
scientists also will say
something along the lines of 50 of what
we know is wrong we just don't know
which 50
right and that's especially true when
trying to
identify mechanisms right most of the
things
including many pharmaceuticals work
not because we understand how they work
but despite the fact that we don't
really know how they work
i think that's also true with a lot of
these exercises in terms of the effects
that they seem to impart
absolutely let me let me ask you a
totally different question and this is
about
visualization or motor imagery okay
so i read in a muscle and fitness
piece your description of visualization
a lot of people
will have heard this term before right
but let me let me just read this
paragraph
because i want to zoom in on the second
part of this
and feel free to fact check this if it
isn't accurate but here's what it says
i'm just pretty sure this is attributed
to you
visualization or what's called motor
imagery is crucial so when you're under
the bar you know exactly what to do the
more detail you go into the better
walking or driving to the gym putting
your shoes on the sounds putting chalk
on your hands grabbing the bar the smell
of the iron the feeling in your hands
and the successful
execution of lift and detail now this
will sound familiar to a lot of folks
right if they've ever watched
the aerial skiers the acrobats in the
winter olympics preparing before a run
or divers or really any high level
athlete they will recognize
visualization of that type and on some
level
then we continue to the second part of
the quote from you which is the second
part which i believe to be even more
important is visualizing a negative
outcome
we don't want to plan for it but we need
to prepare for it so we know how to
react can you keep it together and try
again or will you crumble under pressure
i've never read anything like this
before could you please elaborate
and give an example of that second part
visualizing a negative outcome and how
you use that yeah absolutely
you know i think part of the way that we
react to certain situations is related
to how prepared
we are for that situation and when it
comes to negative outcomes
you know especially as athletes we're
told to always keep a positive
attitude we're always taught to think
positively to not think about it
anything going wrong and i think that
does
a disservice because things are gonna go
wrong
at one point or the other it doesn't
matter what your winning streak is
when you're a boxer an mma fighter a
power lifter there's going to be a point
where it's not going to go your way and
how you react to that
is dependent on how prepared you were to
deal with that situation
so i actually started working with a
sports psychologist
after i bombed out of that meet that we
were talking about because
you start doubting yourself you start
doubting your ability to make lifts on a
platform
pressure starts setting in you you have
this all these expectations by
other people by yourself and it really
terrified me to go back on the platform
after that happened i was embarrassed
i was really embarrassed yeah and
instead of avoiding
those thoughts you know that the the
thought of things going
wrong was it was what was in my mind
every single day after that well what if
that happens to me again
and then i ask myself the question well
what if that happens to me again
like how am i gonna respond like i i
should probably have a plan
of you know what i'm gonna do if that
ever happens again
so i started visualizing like i said
negative outcomes so i go
i go through the same beginning of the
visual imagery
starting from putting my singlet on
putting my shoes on
they call my name the bar is loaded go
on to the platform
i say it's a squat i squat and i miss
okay what am i gonna do and i just
played with different scenarios of how i
was gonna react to a situation like that
and what's interesting is that what
would be some examples of how you might
respond
that you would visualize so how i've
responded in the past was i've cried
hysterically terrified that i wasn't
going to make my next attempt
i've been really angry assign the blame
to someone else oh it's my coach's fault
for
picking the wrong weight or it's the
judge's fault it was actually a good
lift it's their fault for not seeing it
they don't like me the person who
wrapped my knees they don't know what
they're doing
my left part of my knee was hurting me i
would have just assigned a blame to
something external to someone else and
subsequently just have you know be upset
or sad or angry or
whatever it might be and so when you're
visualizing these negative outcomes
are you visualizing those responses or
different responses so
i would practice i would practice going
through different scenarios and
and when i arrived at one that i thought
would be the best course of action
and that's what i stick to and what's
interesting is that the next time i
compete
it was the same competition just the
following year
and i got up there i was more prepared
than i had
ever been i had been doing sports
psychology for an entire year i took
time off after my injury
i was feeling strong i was making a ton
of progress feeling confident
and i got up to a platform and i missed
my first
squat attempt which is something that i
could have done that i had done
in training for five reps so it's
relatively light like if something that
you can do for five reps is like you're
80 85
and i missed it on depth so
the judges from the side didn't think
that my hip crease was below my knee
that's how they determine depth
and they gave me red lights you know
previously i would have reacted to that
very upset i would have you know
blamed them for not seeing the right
thing or whatever
and i mean i just totally brushed it off
like i was i felt like i had
been there a million times and you know
when
my my fiance was there he's like all
worried about how i'm gonna react
because in previous situations i would
have been very upset
and it would have thrown me completely
off my game
and instead i just kind of laughed it
off and was like i've been here before i
know exactly what to do
don't worry what had you rehearsed for
that situation that you landed on
as as your choice exactly that
that i know what to do that i trusted my
capabilities that i was prepared that i
had
trained really well that i was feeling
strong i just kept repeating that to
myself that it was just a fluke
you know that i'm gonna go back in there
back up there and i'm gonna crush the
second attempt was funny as i went up
for the second attempt and got red
lighted again
so at that time i mean i was pretty much
reliving
my experience from the previous year the
us open and you get three shots is that
right
three shots yeah but same thing i was
totally
calm collected i just didn't
again i didn't um my perception of that
failure was completely different i just
thought of it as part of the game as
something that happens
that doesn't mean anything about my
strength levels it doesn't mean anything
about my
abilities as an athlete but what does
determine what my abilities as an
athlete are how can i respond to
unfortunate situations during training
how how fast can i pivot
right how fast can i adapt to the
competition standards you know because
judges are different every time
bars are different platforms are
different so the better athlete is the
one that can
adjust to those changes in competition
standards
the fastest and so that's what i did so
you left us with a cliffhanger so you
got red lights for two attempts
what happened for your third attempt on
the squat and what happened for
the lift or excuse me for the meat yeah
so i actually ended up going
up in weight even though i had missed my
first two attempts
just because i was that sure that i had
that i could do it like i just
i knew it i'd been there before in my
mind so i went up and weighed and i
ended up making it
were there any other particular tools or
benefits
maybe tools that you brought with you
after doing a year
or roughly working a year with sports
psychologists we worked a lot
on especially being someone that's so
open on social media i
i felt like a lot of the pressure that i
was feeling was imparted on me by
just externally but it's it's made up in
my mind right it's like i felt
like everyone was expecting something
from me
so i guess it was just circling back at
what my why is why am i doing what i'm
doing what am i trying to prove
is it for myself is it for other people
and just always trying to circle back
and remember why i started this journey
and
what does it mean to me yeah and another
thing i guess was
working on staying positive when you
encounter
bad training days because you know a lot
of people see your instagram or your
youtube videos you're training
and they think that you never have bad
days that you have some
super human willpower and motivation
and the reality is that it's we we all
experience the same things you know we
all go through days or weeks or months
or years
where we are completely unmotivated and
we don't want to do a certain thing so
working on how to stay positive when
things don't go your way
when training sucks when you don't make
progress
when you fail reps every session when
you feel like
absolute crap when 50 feels like 110
how do you stay positive and how do you
how are you able to show up to the gym
the next day without
you know without bringing that baggage
from the previous session
uh on to your to your next session and a
story that really resonated with me
was and i forgot where i read this what
book it was but
it was about a professional golfer that
he would
literally not admit to himself or the
media or anyone
that he had lost a game he would just
totally erase that fact from his memory
and just continue on as if nothing
happened
and i started doing that and honestly my
my training
started going so much better once i was
able to let go
of my disappointment on a particular
session
and once i stopped generalizing
a bad outcome in a session to you know
my entire block or
i stopped thinking overly thinking about
what that meant
in terms of who i am as an athlete or as
a person
you mentioned books so i'm going to grab
that
are there any particular books that
you've gifted the most to other people
or recommended the obstacle is the way
by ryan holiday yeah yeah he's my
neighbor he's about 40 minutes from
where i'm sitting
40 minutes from where i'm sitting right
now yeah i love that book so much man
yeah it's excellent any others that come
to mind yeah then i have with winning in
mind
i've pretty much gifted that one to any
high level
athlete that i've been able to befriend
so i think it's
just such a powerful lesson i read it a
long time ago but
it's a really amazing read and then
extreme ownership by jocko
jacob willink in extreme ownership if we
go back to the second one just because i
didn't recognize it what was the second
title again with winning in mind by
carol dweck
i believe or no no it's not girl dwight
don't quote me i like i said i
i don't memorize things so with winning
with winning in mind the mental
management system
lanny basham lanny bashing accents yes
yeah
what do you like about that book carol
dweck is the one from mindset
yeah it's mine yes the premise of the
whole
story is is about how you manage your
mind
within your training within your journey
to stay positive
and to continue doing what you love
doing despite obstacles
that's the premise of the book i
wouldn't be able to tell you details but
it really changed the way that i
approached my training and the way i
perceived
ups and downs cool yeah i'm looking at
it
here it's short it's about 162 pages
and i'll give a brief description for
folks uh
in the olympic sport that is most
dependent upon effective and precise
mental management in parentheses rifle
shooting
olympic gold medicine lanny bass hem
b-a-s-s-h-a-m
proved he was the master and then it
goes on and on uh
that sounds like one to pick up yeah and
it's short so you're
so most people will read it now you said
you don't memorize stuff and yet
you have a doctorate in physical therapy
and now that
[Music]
which you know one hand i think is you
believe to have been a great investment
of time but my understanding is that you
did not
take the licensing exam you didn't do
what was expected of you
afterwards so why did you do it why did
you go through it
and how did you do it without memorizing
you must have memorized a hell of a lot
and i forgot it immediately after i saw
my
my brain is just wired a little bit
different man it really is
i'm a lot better at like critical
thinking i'm a lot better at just like
understanding a concept as a whole and
then giving it my own twist and applying
it to like real life situations
so when it comes to like hardcore
memorization like for example
memorizing exact ranges of motion of
each joint or developmental stages and
children
i'm not good at that like i couldn't
tell you a single thing about any of
that
it makes me think this could be an
apocryphal story about henry ford i
think it was and someone asked him
if he knew the vice president of blah
blah blah or something like that and he
couldn't name the person
and this this this other guest who had
made fun of him
was getting up on his high horse and
ford was like that's why i have a
library
so i don't have to clutter my head with
those those details
yeah so why did why did you
why did you pursue your dpt so initially
you know i come from a family that
values uh high level education a lot
you know a family of like lawyers and
doctors and
i think that from a very early age i
guess i started
associating the word success with a with
a high degree like a
high level of education either going to
medical school or at least
at the very least getting a doctorate or
a master's or something like that
so part of it i think was just uh
pressure from my family
initially and i guess personally it's
something that i also value like the
prestige
of being able to say that you're uh
graduate from a top school and that you
were able to complete a program that
only you know one percent or less of the
population gets into
that to me was all sounded amazing and i
love a challenge
so that was part of the reason and the
next part was
anything that i get into i want to make
sure that
i'm giving it you know my my best effort
so if being
in fitness if being in strength and
conditioning was my goal if i wanted to
be a trainer or whatever it was
the highest kind of degree or highest
level of learning that i could do
was was a doctorate level degree
physical therapy seemed
like it would give me the tools to be
the best trainer the best coach the best
athlete
that i could be so that was part of the
reason now
when i was in my first year of grad
school i
started my own business but hold on
before i go there so
first year of grad school i had already
gone through
one of my clinical rotations and
honestly
like i just was having such a i had a
not a great experience in grad school
mainly because of how
mainly because of the system right like
i felt like
or not i felt i knew because i was able
to prove it that
most of the information that was being
thrown at us was extremely outdated
and pretty much the purpose of all of it
was one to test
to test your your commitment to the
profession like to test how bad you
wanted it you know you're taking
i don't know something ridiculous like
six to eight classes a semester and
there's just so much information that
i didn't find applicable at all and was
just so
outdated and professors were so
resistant
to challenges you know i'd be that
person sitting in the back row
raising my hand and challenging you know
something that the professors
said factually or with a lot of
confidence and they wouldn't like that
they don't like
when they're being questioned they don't
like when there's a student that doesn't
believe what they're saying and
and asks things that they
don't know how to answer so there was a
lot of a lot of resistance there like
with in school
with my professors and then when it came
to practice when i went on to my first
clinical rotation
uh it was an experience a little bit of
what the general field of physical
therapy is like
it just wasn't what i thought it was
going to be you know when you're
in a big clinic you're expected to see
at least two patients at a time i didn't
feel like patients were receiving
the best service or the best care at all
because you're so
all over the place having to do your
notes and all of this and i remember
this one experience i had with
my first evaluation that i ever did i
was in the room
my patient and i do everything by the
book right so you have this
steps abcde steps that you have to do
when you're taking a history
uh and you're doing your exam you're
doing your evaluation you're doing your
follow-up questions then you do you're
doing your special tests
and then you give a diagnosis so i went
through all of it perfectly
did my special tests and got something
that made no sense
you know like i got all positive tests
or like
three positives one negative that didn't
make sense with any diagnosis that i had
studied in my book
and i excused myself for a second for
the patient i said hey i'll be right
back
go outside i talk to my uh instructor my
supervisor
and i say hey man you know i did all
these special tests nothing makes sense
i don't know what's wrong with this
person's shoulder
and he just says well make something up
just give him a diagnosis any
and i was just so shocked i was so
shocked because
i used to look up to him right as he he
was a mentor he was a supervisor he was
an instructor and the fact that
that was his answer and coupled with
just the experience i had with my back
pain and the lack of consistency and
responses
just made it so evident that that school
wasn't doing what i was supposed to do
for people
that we were going into a practical
field with no practical
knowledge essentially where we we have a
bunch of knowledge
that is only useful for one thing and
that's to pass the licensure test
so that's why i didn't go that route who
are some of the people
out there if any come to mind who have
doctor in physical therapy whose
insights or work
you track or admire who you who you
think do good
practical work greg lehmann
is the first one that comes to mind how
do you spell that gregan
lehmann l-e-h-m-a-n
he why do you say that so he's uh yeah
he's
i think the first degree he got was in
chiropractic
so he went to school to study get his
chiropractic degree
then he went on to studying getting a
doctorate in biomechanics
and then he went back to physical
therapy school so he's done
in terms of breadth of experience and
knowledge
in different camps of thought he has it
all
right he has the perspective as a cairo
he has a perspective as a scientist
conducts research in biomechanics and
understands
the physics of the body and then
physical therapy which is more of a
science of movement so i mean his
lectures are
absolutely amazing he's able to
incorporate a little bit of everything
into the way that he treats and has a
really interesting perspective
i've actually had a few sessions with
him they're all
they're all done over uh zoom i think he
very rarely
practices in person very rarely puts his
hands on anyone because
he's been his whole thing is how can you
deliver or
how can you place the power
on the patient instead of positioning
yourself as a guru as like some
someone that people save your savior pt
right
so it's it's about giving the power to
the patient
and it should be about patient
self-reliance about
them building a sense of autonomy and
self-efficacy as early as possible
instead of having them be overly reliant
on you as a therapist so
most of my sessions you know were an
hour an hour and a half long
and there were long discussions about a
lot of things
because there's a lot of things that
affect your perception of pain like we
were saying
so stress my environment my coping
strategies
perceptions on movements and all of
these things
like a great example is for example if
you have a paper cut
on your finger like how much importance
are you going to place on that you
personally
but you probably put a band-aid on and
move on and not think about it
until it heals and then the band-aid
falls off and then you're fine
but a violin player gets a paper cut
on their finger that they use to press
on those strings
and their response to pain and
their association with that injury is
going to be completely different to
yours
because within the context and within
his profession that means a lot more
to that person so it's important going
back to greg he places a lot of
importance on those conversations like
what does an injury mean to you in the
context of your life and
that's smart yeah and it's just it's
it's super super
interesting the way that he treats what
have you changed your mind on
in the last handful of years anything
stand out
yeah i love telling this story when i
was in um
college and i stopped playing soccer
i was kind of like on this quest to
rediscovering myself and finding what
the next thing was going to be same
same as far as what what profession i
wanted to get into
you know you're thrown in college and
you're expected to know what you want to
study that's crazy i think there's only
a handful of people
that know with absolute certainty what
they want to be when they grow up
you know it's like you're plastic
surgeons like those kids were playing
with
surgical kids when they were three and
just know that that's what they love and
that's what they're passionate about or
have been conditioned to think that
that's what they want
either way that wasn't my case i had a
very vague idea of where i wanted to be
i knew i wanted to be you know a public
figure i knew i wanted to lecture i want
i knew i wanted to write a book i knew i
wanted to be a professional athlete but
i wasn't necessarily attached to any one
route or any one path
so for the longest time i spent a long
time in this discovery period or
sampling period
where i would get into something i would
try it for
sometimes for a long time sometimes for
a short time and then i would quit and
move on to the next thing
but it was strategic quitting just i
didn't know it at the time and
the person i was dating at that time my
my ex-boyfriend
he one time he's i remember i got a
specialized bike because i wanted to get
into triathlons
and he criticized that a lot he said
steph why are you
investing so much money into a bike when
everything you try you quit
almost immediately you're a quitter and
that was that was shocking to me
especially coming from someone's you
know
so close to me that he was calling me a
quitter and i just didn't
i didn't identify myself as a quitter i
would feel like it was the complete
opposite
you know i'm resilient i'm persistent
i'm consistent no i'm not a quitter
but i was right like within the
classical definition of quitting
yeah it was i was trying a bunch of
different things and quitting a bunch of
things
but like i said it was more strategic
than anything i was just trying to
trying to discover myself and what i'm
good at and the way i think about it
is there's kind of like in my head how i
separate it is
there's three kind of components to
finding something that you're good at
you have your your skills
your talents and your passions and what
you're essentially trying to do
is find the best balance of the three
you shouldn't hope to put again all of
your eggs in one basket it's not only
about what you're passionate about which
is
is part of the worst advice that people
can can give you is do what you love
i couldn't disagree with that more
because it's about finding that balance
between
your skills so it's your skills are
something that you can work at
that you can you see progress when you
practice it
your talents is an inherent ability so
something that you're born with like for
example i was
born like physiologically to have the
capability to get stronger so that's
the talent i have that's something that
you can't really teach and then a
passion is something that you're
interested in
the funny thing is that when your skills
and talents
match up you can start developing a
passion for that because everyone likes
to be successful
so you can start developing a passion or
a love for something that you didn't
know you're passionate about just
because
you are you're standing out from the
crowd so
for me that sampling period was so
important because i was
able to find stuff that i was really
really good at sports that i was really
really good at
in a profession that i was really really
good at because i was curious because
the way that i think about things was
scientific and
i was able to excel in those things
because because i sampled
so the notion that winners never quit
is just so flawed is such a fallacy
and it does such a disservice to people
because it
discourages people from trying new
things because they're afraid
that they're they're not gonna like it
or they're gonna be bad at it or they're
afraid to fail
and the reality is that it's it's a good
thing
it's a good thing especially when you
quit for the right reasons so what what
are the right reasons to quitting
is when you identify that there's like
an upper
limit for where you can get you know you
identify
maybe uh something within yourself that
you
that you won't be able to overcome that
you just won't be able to be better than
your competition
versus quitting for the wrong reasons
which is quitting when you first
encounter resistance
you know that's cowardly because things
are gonna get tough at some point you
just gotta know
you just gotta be very strategic again
like i said of
when you're quitting and not being
afraid to quit
for those reasons and i think i read
this on
i believe it's the dip by seth godin the
sunk cost fallacy
so it's basically when you've invested
some time or money
into something it kind of tricks you
into
not wanting to leave it because
perceptually you're like oh
i've already spent all this time it's
it's what happened to me in pt school
i think well that's one of the reasons
why i didn't quit was because i had
already invested
a year of my life in a year of tuition
into that and i was like you know i
might as well
stay obviously there were other reasons
for me to stay and it ended up
ended up being really positive for me
but that's what keeps people in jobs
they hate
that's what keeps people from not taking
a risk and starting their own business
or
not switching sports or careers or
friendships or partners
so winners never quit and quitters never
win false
in the life experience of steffi cohen
and by the way yeah she's broken 25
world records so
most of you most of y'all can just shut
the [ __ ] up uh
so yeah although it does take a certain
sensitivity
and degree of refined
perception and self-awareness to
identify what you are
good at and not trick yourself into
thinking that you are just
sampling when in fact you are stopping
due to pain or discomfort or setbacks or
plateaus right so
it does require a certain amount of
reflection
to go through that sampling period and
then double down and triple down
on a few areas or one area where you
truly have
an advantage that you can learn to love
yeah it does take some awareness
absolutely and and you'll make you'll
make that poor decision sometimes
for example i think i made the wrong
decision when it came to soccer
the reason why i stopped playing soccer
i think wasn't the right one if
if there's one thing i could change
about my past would have been to to try
harder
instead of soccer yeah let's talk about
something that popped up when i was
texting with a few people who know you
uh adi caju
prompted me to ask about time management
whether
it was all time well invested or not you
completed
your doctorate while training to break
25 world records and
simultaneously creating a successful
business which i think
we haven't spent a whole lot of time on
but you have you have built and scaled
business very successfully so you're
doing all of those things simultaneously
at least at one point in time
how do you think about time management
or what are some of the key
components to doing that much
simultaneously yeah what sacrifices are
made or how would you encourage people
to think about it because
that does seem to be uh
unusual capacity to do that
i actually i love this question because
i have a very non-traditional answer
i think a lot of quote unquote
high achievers or high performers
have this seemingly very well
constructed and organized
weekly monthly yearly schedules where
they're where everything's planned they
have like
you know times where they do certain
things and times where they don't times
where they
whatever like they're very they seem to
be very organized and for a long time
i tried to be that way you know read
things like the seven habits of highly
effective people
and the four hour work week and i was
always yeah
burn that second one terrible advice
and i just felt so frustrated because i
didn't feel
like i was like everyone else so to a
certain extent i felt uh
like i was an imposter i'm a lazy
successful person
that's that's how i would feel i'm
pretending that i have all the habits of
all these successful people when in
reality
i'm not like them i do things very
differently you know i don't do well
with
inflexible schedules i don't have an
agenda that's all color coded and
highlighted
i don't have morning ritual i really
don't i'm
more of like a free spirit i'm a
procrastinator i am unorganized
my mind is all over the place oh hold on
though
i mean that having been said it's not
like you're just eating cheetos and
watching reruns of seinfeld and
you know smoking out of a bong all day
no to when you're getting a dpt and the
training and the successful business
done at the same time so
as a free spirit how the hell does that
how does
how does that get done right so i mean
just
for the longest time i tried to be like
other people and i just found that
it's just not it wasn't going to work
for me so
the way i do things is i focus on the
task at hand
so what do i need to do right now to
either finish a project or to move in
the right direction and i do that
and i i used to cycle it based on
prioritizing so for example when while i
was in physical therapy school i knew
that there would come weeks of increased
workload when i was doing practicals or
when i was doing
or there was a thesis or there were
midterms or final exams i knew those
times were high stress and
i knew that whether i liked it or not i
was going to have to spend
extra time inside studying which is why
i actually built a home gym in my living
room when i was in pt school in a second
floor apartment
it's probably not the smartest thing to
do but
your neighbors downstairs loved you they
hated me
they thought i was insane
but um yeah you know that's that's what
i had to do so when those times would
come in pressure was on it was time to
study
i would just come to terms that accept
that training was gonna take the back
seat and hybrid my business was going to
take the back seat for those two weeks
while i focused on this
one very important thing which is
staying in school which was
more difficult than it sounds because
they had a very strict policy where if
you got anything less than a 75
on any test you would get kicked out
which i did
but we're gonna cut we we're gonna have
to come back to that
so okay continue so so yeah i just
focused on the task at hand if there
were tests coming up i would focus all
my energy on that and i would
train as much as i could whether it was
a 10-minute workout or a 20-minute
workout it didn't matter and i
didn't feel pressured to spend any more
time at the gym because i knew
that once you know once the midterms or
finals
were done i was gonna have more time and
then when that was done i would double
down on
on my training and my business i would
skip class i would spend
four or five hours at the gym i would do
double sessions when i had the time
so i just basically played it by ear i
did what i had to do when i had to do it
and somehow everything got done it
sounds like
you may correct me from wrong but you're
very good at single tasking right you're
not multitasking you're not doing 17
different things in a given day
you are identifying for the next two or
four weeks or two months or four months
whatever it might be
what the most important thing is to move
forward and then you just
basically drop everything else and maybe
not drop but you
you focus almost all of your energy on
that one thing exactly
you get kicked out of school this is for
getting less than 75 on a test dude
that was a horrific experience let me
tell you
so i i've never i've never failed a test
in my life even though you know in
college i wasn't that applied in high
school i was i
wasn't that applied i somehow always
passed my tests you know i'm like a
b-plus student
and somehow i failed this test of
the silliest class ever you know that
class
that you think to yourself ah this is
such an easy test i don't even have to
study
that was that was that type of class
yeah and
i took my test i disconnected completely
i went to canada for christmas with with
hayden with my fiance didn't think about
school
at all then all of a sudden i get back
home you know two or three weeks later
and there's a pile a pile of letters
from the head
of the school the head administrator of
the school and i'm like oh my god it's
not good
i opened them up and basically there was
the first one that said hi
you have seven days to submit an appeal
you failed
i think it was evaluation treatments and
evaluation class
with a 74 you have to submit an appeal
in seven days otherwise you're going to
be dismissed from the program
and then there was letters like every
day after that day
saying you know we haven't heard from
you we're taking you out of the roster
we're taking you out of the class we're
kicking you out of the program because
we didn't hear from you
essentially and that was the most
terrifying moment of my life i just felt
like such a loser i felt like
i was you know getting kicked out of
school that's big
anyway you know i made an appointment to
speak with the head of admissions and to
speak with the entire
committee of academic review and they
ended up
giving me an appointment giving me an
opportunity to appeal
given the circumstances i didn't really
know that they were trying to contact me
i just kind of disconnected i didn't
expect
to fail a test i guess and i sat down in
a room with
with i guess there were 15 or 20
professors it was a round table
huge round table and i'm in the middle
and pretty much you know i'm just being
asked why do i deserve a second chance
why they should let me back in why do i
think i failed what am i going to do
different
but the question or the statement i
guess that stood out to me the most was
this one professor his name is dr fybert
which
by the way i love him now and i think i
love him more because he challenged me
i guess that's how i that's why i
perform my best when there's a challenge
when people don't believe in me
so he stared at me right in the eye and
he goes steph i just think the problem
here is that you're not as strong as a
student as you think you are
and i think you're going to have to make
the decision between becoming a
professional athlete or becoming a
professional student
but i don't think you're capable of
doing both
and i just looked at him in the eyes and
i said professor fiber you know with all
due respect i appreciate your
your criticism but i just i have to
disagree with that statement i think
what happened was a fluke
i think i'm more than capable as a
student i think i'm more than capable to
do both things i just
wasn't focused on on the right thing i
wish something happened with that test i
didn't focus enough didn't study enough
but i think i'm capable of doing it
and they ended up granting me a second
chance but from there on that was
my first second semester of grad school
and from there on i just
my professors were all up in my ass
basically for the end
until until i graduated because they
just thought i was this rebel i would
i would get to school more often than
not late probably from training
with a barbell in my hand because i
would train uh at noon
as well so i would take the lunch break
the train
you carried your barbell with my barbell
[Laughter]
don't call me a meathead i'm just
carrying my barbell around the class
don't mind me there's nothing to see
here yeah
and meanwhile my spine professor would
be like you're gonna break your back
doing all those dead lifts you know
people thought it was crazy
but yeah i made it i didn't fail a
single more test
for the entire three years was the most
honestly the most stressful three years
of my life just because i felt like
getting kicked out was so imminent you
know i just felt like i was one slip
away from
being picked up yeah just waiting for
the other shoe to drop
but i made it but you made it you made
it
and and much more so let's let's do
a few more questions and then we can we
can bring around
round one to a close i know we didn't
get a chance to talk about diet you are
uh exceptionally expert in diets we
haven't had a chance to discuss that we
have another chance to talk about boxing
there's a lot there's a lot we could
explore we're not gonna have a chance to
explore
today but let me ask you two things
aside from school and
the failing of that test do you have any
favorite failures
that you learned a lot from or that
set you up for in some way later success
could be also a dark period but just any
anything
particularly challenging that comes to
mind that
in some way ended up helping you yeah so
actually
my favorite quote and this is the only
quote i have memorized
is each fresh crisis is an opportunity
in disguise
i can remember where i first read it but
it resonated with me so much because
honestly
every single time i've failed at
something it's been
the best worst thing that has ever
happened to me
it's opened so many doors and so many
new opportunities
when you look for them they're there so
i think every
single time i've experienced any sort of
failure
i've been able to get out of it better
than ever
i guess one of the most biggest ones was
getting
kicked out of school and just having to
like reframe how i thought about school
and how i studied and my habits and how
i organized my study my training
but aside from that i mean there's many
moving to the us
on my own you know starting with like a
2.5 gpa
not knowing if i was going to be able to
stay in school not understanding the
language
having to take multiple steps back and
several classes retake classes
that led me to discover other passions
well you're bombing out in that
competition probably in some way yeah
failed relationships
infidelity issues with partners
that led me to kind of rediscover myself
and change my perceptions on
relationships and
what kind of things i can do better to
be a better partner
friendships ending failed friendships
failed relationships with my family with
my dad
that all ended up teaching me a ton you
know i think that society glorifies
happiness
society glorifies you know being in a
good mood and being happy and being
positive
and fails to acknowledge the important
lessons
that happen when you're going through
dark periods of time when you're going
through
tough times and so i mean those are so
important look at the beginning of this
year when the pandemic first started
i did my last powerlifting competition
of this year in
february and my back pain got
exacerbated a lot
i did a massive weight cut i cut like 20
pounds and a period of like two weeks
i broke some world records and then my
back was flared up worse than ever
and it's upsetting it's frustrating
especially after you know i wrote a book
about back pain and i'm having a hard
time managing it
so i fell into this really deep
depression because i felt like my
identity was being stripped out of me my
identity as an athlete my identity as a
high level top performer my my identity
as an authority
in academia when it comes to back pain
when it comes to injuries when it comes
to strength training i felt like i
didn't know what i was talking about
anymore because i couldn't even figure
it out for myself
and you know that coupled that with with
a pandemic
everything closing off i felt like my
life was just kind of spiraling
downwards out of control i spent a
couple weeks like that just being
feeling
pity for myself feeling really bad about
the situation about the cards that i was
dealt about my back about
potentially not being able to lift again
i didn't know about the livelihood
of my business how is how is the
pandemic going to impact my
my income and all of these other things
that just you know
created an unsurmountable amount of
anxiety for me
and i think when that passes i think
it's like just it's part of the process
to go through those
a couple weeks or a month it i do
believe it's important to give yourself
a time cap for how long you're gonna
feel bad for yourself because otherwise
she just end up stuck in that face for
way too long
so i remember just making the conscious
decision to stop feeling bad about
myself and about my situation and trying
to
to see the positive and the
opportunities that lied within that
so when it came to sports i bought a
heavy bag
and i put it in my garage and that led
to kareem my new coach reaching out to
me and wanting to
make me a pro fighter that opened you
know the possibility for me to get into
a new sport
and then the pandemic closed the door
for networking for example that was a
big part of how i gained exposure i
traveled for podcasts i lectured
i appeared on youtube videos that was a
big competitions were cancelled
so i initially was really worried about
how that was going to impact my
my ability to continue growing my
business and growing my my social
platform and
i guess my personal brand so i
doubled down on other things like we
created a whole series of master classes
that we're starting to offer
uh we created like five courses we
finished our coach's certification for
hybrid we're
writing a manuscript a full textbook we
invested in our team we found new
software developers
we you know we did so many good things
for the business
that i guess we wouldn't have done if
everything
stayed the same and it ended up being
everything was okay you know and i think
it's that change of mindset that change
of
trying to find the opportunities within
what seems like the worst thing that
could have ever happened to you
and they're always there it's just a
matter of changing your attitude your
perception
of what failure is and finding ways to
see the beauty in that failure and what
kind of opportunities present
on the other side each fresh crisis is
an
opportunity in disguise good advice
good maxim for life in general
and uh fingers crossed for 2021
but no matter what transpires yeah
always
always looking for the opportunity
hidden in the crisis excellent advice
steph this has been so much fun people
can find
you all over the place
hybridperformancemethod.com instagram
at steffi cohen s-t-e-f-i-c-o-h-e-n
on youtube you have your podcast hybrid
unlimited
is there anything else you would like to
say or
ask of the audience any closing comments
anything at all that you'd like to share
before we bring this first conversation
to a close
i think the only thing that i wasn't
able to address because we kept getting
sidetracked on on side stories was the
uh summary of recommendations that you
were asking me like what do you do when
you have an
injury like step by step do you want me
to go through that like
quickly yeah i'll do just one two three
four five
six like the bullet points lightning
rounds yes
so when you're hurt these are the six
things that you should be doing
any injury this applies to any injury
the first thing is stop doing what hurts
it seems like common sense ago but at
the same time it's something that a lot
of people
trick themselves into thinking they
don't need that's definitely always
the first step so take a step back and
don't be afraid of
taking some time off you know you take
one step back two steps forward kind of
thing
don't underestimate isometric exercises
or
or seemingly simple exercises because
it's all about delivering positive
movement experiences when you're in pain
so it's about finding movements that
feel good to you and that don't
exacerbate
your pain increasing the amount of
aerobic activity that you do
so walking more moving more in general
there's a saying in pt that's overstated
but motion is lotion
and that is true you know the more that
you move more blood flow goes into your
joints
the better it is and the more you avoid
that deconditioning loop because what a
lot of people tend to do when they're in
pain is they stop moving
all together because they think that
that's what they need but bed rest and
immobilization
is all outdated you want to move as much
as as you can
essentially using pain to optimize your
movement
so knowing so the way that i think about
it is kind of like a stop light
zero to three out of ten of pain means
go three to six
means warning and over sex means
definitely don't do that
so use pain to inform your training
decisions and the movements that you do
once you've done all of that you got to
turn off the pain alarm so for a period
of time
it's okay to avoid certain movements but
then you know you shouldn't be avoiding
movements forever
so starting to expose yourself to
tolerable ranges of motion and tolerable
movements that don't make your pain
worse
so that you can get back to the
movements that you used to do that bring
joy to your life
and then understanding the final one is
understanding that tissue adaptation
takes time so
sometimes we're married to this very
rigid
healing times that we see on the
internet we're like okay how long does
it take for an elbow injury to heal okay
two to four weeks and then four weeks go
by and you're still in pain and you
think something's wrong with you
but oftentimes nothing's wrong with you
you just have different sensitivities
to pain and different ways that we deal
with it and
different healing times and so just
don't rush the process
and understand that everyone experiences
pain and injuries
at a different speed that's it and
that's it
the new book is back in motion back in
motion i i've been very impressed with
a lot of the writing and can't wait to
see what you do next
especially with boxing looking forward
to seeing the infighting
and i would not want to get punched by
you uh
so i will remain on the sidelines
clapping like a fan
fanboy uh we've mentioned a couple of
different options for people to find you
are there any other places or resources
you'd like to mention no that's all
cover them all all right well steph
thank you so much
for taking the time today to be on the
show
and to everyone listening we will have
links
to all the topics all the people all the
books all the exercises and so on that
came up
today you'll be able to find those as
usual i tend up blog forward slash
podcast and until next time
each fresh crisis is an opportunity to
disguise keep it in mind
enjoy variability pay attention to your
gpp
and thanks for tuning in hey guys this
is tim again just a few more things
before you take off
number one this is five bullet friday
do you want to get a short email from me
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every friday
that provides a little more soul of fun
before the weekend and five bullet
friday is a very short email
where i share the coolest things i've
found or that i've been pondering over
the week
that could include favorite new albums
that i've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that i've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as i do
it could include
favorite articles that i've read and
that i've shared with
my close friends for instance and it's
very short
it's just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off for the weekend so
if you want to receive that
check it out just go to four hour
workweek.com that's 4hourworkweek.com
all spelled out and just drop in
your email and you will get the very
next one and if you sign up
i hope you enjoy it this episode is
brought to you by
element spelled lmnt what on earth is
element
it is a delicious sugar-free electrolyte
drink mix
i've stocked up on boxes and boxes of
this it was one of the first things that
i bought
when i saw a copic coming down the pike
and i usually use one to two per day
element is formulated to help anyone
with their electrolyte needs and
perfectly suited to folks following a
keto low carb or paleo diet or if you
drink a ton of water and you might not
have the right balance that's often when
i drink it or if you're doing any type
of endurance exercise
mountain biking etc another application
if you've ever struggled to feel good
on keto low carb or paleo it's most
likely because even if you're
consciously consuming electrolytes
you're just not getting enough and it
relates to a bunch of stuff like a
hormone called aldosterone blah blah
blah when insulin is low but suffice to
say
this is where element again spelled lmnt
can help my favorite flavor by far is
citrus salt
which is a side note you can also use to
make a kick-ass
no-sugar margarita but for special
occasions obviously
you're probably already familiar with
one of the names behind it
rob wolf r-o-b-b rob wolf who is a
former research biochemist and
two-time new york times best-selling
author of the paleo solution and wired
to eat
rob created element by scratching his
own h
that's how it got started his brazilian
jiu jitsu coaches turned him on onto
electrolytes
as a performance enhancer things clicked
and bam
company was born so if you're on a low
carb diet or
fasting electrolytes play a key role in
relieving hunger cramps headaches
tiredness
and dizziness sugar artificial
ingredients coloring
all that's garbage unneeded there's none
of that in element
and a lot of names you might recognize
are already using element it was
recommended to be
by one of my favorite athlete friends
three navy seal teams as prescribed by
their master chief
marine units fbi sniper teams at least
five nfl teams who have subscriptions
they are the exclusive hydration partner
to team usa weightlifting and on and on
you can try it risk free
if you don't like it element will give
you your money back no questions asked
they have extremely low return rates
element came up with a very special
offer for you my dear listeners for a
limited time you can claim a
free element sample pack you only cover
the cost of shipping
for u.s customers this means you can
receive an eight count sample pack
for just five dollars simply go to drink
elements dot com slash tim
that's drink lmnt.com tim to claim your
free eight count sample pack
one more time that's drink lmnt.com
for this exclusive offer
drinkelements.com
tim check it out this episode is brought
to you by
tonal t-o-n-a-l i'm super excited about
this one
and i was skeptical of it in the
beginning total
quote tonal is the world's most
intelligent home gym and personal
trainer end quote that's the tagline
from their website folks to give you the
one sentence summary and
this device it's really a system is
perfect for anyone looking to take their
home workouts to the next level or
someone who just wants to get
maximum bang for the buck in a tiny tiny
footprint of space
tonal is precision engineered to be the
world's most advanced strength studio
and personal trainer it uses
breakthrough technology of all different
types
to help get you stronger faster i was
introduced to tonal by three different
friends all of them are tech savvy
one of them is a former competitive
skier who's doubled his strength in a
number of moments using tonal even
though he has a
long athletic background and i'll paint
a picture for you by eliminating
traditional metal weights
dumbbells and barbells tonal can deliver
200 pounds of resistance which doesn't
sound like a lot but it's actually
it feels like a lot more at the high end
in a device smaller than a flat screen
tv and you can perform at least 150
different exercises and these different
technologies are exclusive to tonal
you can dial weights up and down with
the touch of a button in one pound
increments
using magnets and electricity so the
movement is extremely smooth
and even though i have a home gym
already in my garage i'm still
getting eternal installed i've used
tonal for multiple workouts now
to do things i just cannot do in my home
gym such as the chop and lift exercises
from the 4-hour body all sorts of cable
exercises that would usually
involve much much bigger piece of
equipment eccentric
training for instance you can do to give
a simple example
bicep curls where you are lifting let's
just say
20 pounds in each hand up and then total
will automatically
increase the weight because you can
lower more than you can lift to say
25 or 30 pounds on the way down and i do
kettlebell swings i do all sorts of
deadlifts this that the other thing and
after
one workout on tonal focusing on pulling
i was blasted for a full
week it's really incredible what you can
do with eccentrics
they also have all sorts of other really
really cool
advantages that you can apply to any of
your favorite movements
tonal learns from your strength and
provides suggested weight
recommendations for every move with
detailed progress reports to help you
see your strengths grow
total also has a growing library of
expert-led workouts by motivating
coaches from strength training
to cardio so you can do really just
about everything every program is
personalized to your body
using artificial intelligence and other
aspects
of the engineering and smart features
check your form in real time just like a
personal trainer
so try it out try tonal at least check
it out watch
the videos on youtube and see if you can
pick out a familiar voice
it's not me i'll say that but try tonal
the world's smartest home gym
for 30 days in your home and if you
don't love it you can return it for a
full refund
so visit www.tonal.com for 100
off of smart accessories when you use
promo code tim
tim at checkout that's www.tonal.com
promo code tim total be your strongest
you